[Music]
hey everyone how's it going today we're
going to be talking about a rumor slash
question that has been going around and
that is will Captain America lift mule
near in Avengers 4 this question comes
from a rumor that has been going around
that says at one point in time Captain
America and Thor fight Thanos together
so this obviously raises a ton of
questions about how this all happens so
it is widely accepted now that Avengers
4 is going to be a time travel movie
and/or a alternate reality movie and
this will obviously have to happen in
Avengers 4 for this scenario to play out
because mule NER is broken it's
shattered it's dead right now fort is
wildung storm breakers so if he's going
to get mule near back they're either
gonna have to go back in time or it's
going to exist in some alternate
timeline it's gonna be pretty easy to
work time travel into Avengers 4
especially with the leaked set photos
that we've already seen I think it's
going to come down to ant-man and Hank
Pym working together with Tony Stark to
create this technology in a way they
already sort of have the technology
because an ant me and they explored the
quantum realm and an ant-man and the
wasp they're going to explore it even
more and that is certainly a way to
explore time travel and an alternate
reality so that answers one how how will
mune there be in the movie for Captain
America to lift up the next how is how
will Captain America be able to lift
Milner up two things
he'll have to be worthy and he'll have
to have a need for it so is Captain
America worthy enough to wield Mjolnir
well in the comics he certainly is he
wields mule near on several occasions
and one vol Thor falls and drops his
hammer and captain picks it up and helps
him defeat his enemies and another vol
Thor actually dies and Captain picks up
the hammer and calls to the Avengers to
assemble so as far as worthiness goes
Captain America is definitely worthy
enough to pick up mule near and at one
point in time Thor himself actually
deemed Captain America worthy enough to
lift mule near
so this kind of started the theory that
you actually have to not only be worthy
enough to lift me on there but you
actually have to have a need to use me
on there in order to lift it an age of
Ultron when all the Avengers were trying
to lift me on there we saw captain
actually move it and maybe that's
because he's worthy enough but didn't
have a need for it at the time so the
unfortunate part about this rumor is
that Captain America will in fact lift
Mjolnir but he will die by Thanos
defending the other Avengers which is
certainly a huge bummer but as far as
needs go saving the lives of your
friends that's a big need so I can
definitely see it happening and would be
crazy awesome to see on screen and like
I said it's happened in the comics this
could actually be pretty likely because
we all know that Chris Evans has not
renewed his contract to play Captain
America after Avengers 4 and since
that's the case it's more than likely
that they're going to kill off Steve
Rogers so that the Captain America
mantle can fall on somebody new so this
is the theory that I've been reading and
hearing going around and I actually
think that it could probably happen it
all lines up with what Avengers 4 is
supposedly trying to do the fact that
mewling there is back lines up with a
time travel aspect of Avengers for
Captain America being worthy enough to
lift me on there it lines up with the
comics and Steve Rogers dying lines up
with the fact that they're supposed to
be major character deaths in Avengers 4
and them not coming back so obviously
it's just the rumor going around there's
no way to tell how true this is but I
can definitely see it as a really
awesome way to kind of save goodbye to
Steve Rogers I can think of this really
big scene towards the end of the movie
where Thanos is about to just kill
everybody
obviously Thor's hurt in some way or
gets hit where he drops his hammer and
Captain America picks it up runs that
Thanos Lightning coming out of the
hammer uses it starts to go one-on-one
with Thanos while the other Avengers are
able to get away and he saves their
lives but then after Santos kills him so
I can see it happening and if they are
going to kill off Steve Rogers this is
sort of the way that I would like him to
go out him sacrificing himself to save
his friends that he loves that's just
who Captain Mary
is and the last scene that we might have
of him it'd be pretty cool to see that
so that's it for this video
I hope you enjoyed it if you did hit
that thumbs up button for me if this
rumor does in fact end up being true let
me know how you feel about this and
don't forget to subscribe to my channel
to stay up to date on Avengers for
Marvel and all things superhero and a
quick note about the giveaway that I did
the winner will be announced in the next
couple of days thank you so much for
watching woof woof
[Music]